[Music]
our each Ella had us begging for more
cuz Ariana Grande pulled out all the
stops for her first performance at
Coachella
the pop star headlined night three of
the annual music festival she's only the
fourth ever woman to do that after
Beyonce Lady Gaga and Bjork
from opening the show with God as a
woman to belting out high notes and hits
off her latest album thank you next ari
did not fail to impress
[Music]
at one point the singer got choked up
performing her song dedicated to her
exes specifically the late rapper Mac
Miller who died of an apparent drug
overdose but emotions were high for a
different reason for fans re surprised
fans with an NSYNC reunion everyone
except Justin Timberlake and gave her
own rendition of a 90s classic
[Music]
days before fans speculated re had
something big up her sleeve
the singer dropped hints of an instinct
present sharing throwback videos of a
young re at the boy bands concert and
this video lip-synching to in sync songs
tearing up my heart and the surprises
didn't stop there
Nicki Minaj joined re on stage to
perform their collab bang bang but they
had a few audio issues then as a tribute
to the fallen hip-hop legends Nipsey
Hussle Mac Miller Tupac and notorious
b.i.g Diddy and Mase made a cameo to
perform their biggie collaboration Mo
Money mo problems
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]